OpenClaw just dropped its new free
update for March the 2nd and it's
packed. We're talking AI that can now
read your PDFs instantly. AI agents who
can talk to each other and hand off
tasks without you lifting a finger.
Realtime responses stream live so it
actually feels like conversation inside
Telegram. Plus over 100 security fixes
so your setup is better than before.
This is not an upgrade. This is a
completely different tool to how it
feels like last week. And here's the
craziest part. is completely free. You
can get updated and set this up today.
We're going to look at every single one
of these new features together right now
live so you can see exactly what this
thing can do and whether it actually
lives up to the hype. If you've been
waiting for one AI tool to run your
entire life, this might be it. Let's
find out. So, we're going to get
straight into this. You can see the
update right here. And this is the
update. Now, the first thing to note
here is the Telegram um streaming
example of the messages, right? So, you
can see the messages and how it comes in
in real time. uh like this inside the
video. So, if you want to see the full
change log, here are all the new updates
like you can see. So, a bunch of
changes, a heavy heavy list of changes
as you can see. There must be what, at
least 50 different changes added to
this. Um, and there's a bunch of new
updates here. Now, if you want to update
this automatically, what you can do is
just go to your config file here. Scroll
down inside open claw if you've got this
running. And then you're going to make
sure that you have auto update enabled
over here. Auto update. Right now, once
you've done that, we're going to go over
to the chat and we're going to click
update now. You can see the notification
here. So, it says the um 2nd of March
update is currently running the 1st of
March update. So, we need to update.
We're going to click on that update now
button. Sometimes this breaks, sometimes
it doesn't work. We're going to figure
out what happens together and test it
out and we'll see how it performs.
So, it's beginning to update now.
Sometimes the gateway breaks. I will
warn you now. But if it does, it's okay
cuz I'll show you exactly how to fix it
along the way and how to get this
working. Now, let's talk about the
update whilst it's beginning to auto
update itself. Um, and we'll talk you
through some of the changes and how it
happens. So, if you've never heard of
OpenClaw before, I'll keep this short,
but you're about to be very happy on
what you stumbled on. This free tool got
one of its biggest updates ever. Um, and
it's basically like a really powerful
sort of AI that runs locally on your
laptop. Um,
and it lets you, for example, connect AI
systems, automate tasks, build custom
workflows, and do all of this. And it's
completely free and open source to use.
You can even connect it to for example
uh Olama or Quen 3.5 and run this
locally without any API costs as well
which is pretty awesome. So
once we've done this we can see it. Now
I'm just going to check the terminal and
make sure that it's working.
Check the logs inside the terminal. When
I actually click update now it doesn't
seem to be but let's see if it's
working. I'm just going to say are you
working? Sometimes it just takes a
little while to respond. So, I'm going
to see what happens uh when we click are
you working. It might have just broken
again. So, let's test it out and then
let's talk about what changed in the
meantime. So, now you get this sort of
live uh messages inside Telegram, right?
So, what that means is that you get the
responses instantly and you can see them
as they go along inside the chat, which
is pretty cool. And then also
you can basically when your AI responds
inside Telegram, the text now appears
word by word in real time just like
watching someone type. So here's the
example, right? So this is an example of
an open call responding and someone said
like send me a 30 line haiku and then it
started to produce the haiku in real
time right here. Right? It's pretty cool
because then you don't have to wait for
the whole message to load. You just get
it um good to go. Right? And so if we go
back inside the chat now I'm just going
to say are you updated to the latest
version because you can see already that
it's it's getting buggy inside the chat
here. So, if we click on update now, it
just it clicks updating and then stops
working, right? Um, so I'm going to see
what it responds with now and just make
sure it is working on the right version.
If not, we might have to run a terminal
command to get it running. Um, or we
could just uninstall it and then
reinstall it again using the newest
updates as well. Let's see what we got
inside the chats here. So, Sakura says,
"What is the best model to run locally
and get results?" Um, so I would
recommend checking out Olama Quen 3.5.
GLM 4.7 Flash is a cloud model, but it
runs locally with OAM, if that makes
sense. So it runs via OAMA, but it's a
cloud API. But if you want like a fully
fully um local way of running OpenC,
then you can use OAMA 3.5. I actually
did a video on it earlier this morning
and created a full guide. You can check
that out inside the AI profit boardroom.
So if you go to the open claw plus aquen
3.5 plus alarm just dropped some smaller
models that are faster to run locally
but still very powerful um and those
were just dropped a few hours ago. So
I've got a full guide and tutorial on
how to set that up as you can see right
here inside the air profit boarding. So
let's go back to the update details now.
And if we go back to open claw
you can see that it says we're actually
ahead. So, it is running the March the
2nd release. There does seem to be some
sort of bug inside the update section.
So, like when I click this, it doesn't
respond, but you can see here that it's
running the March the 2nd update, which
is great. Um, so it's good to go, right?
I'm just going to make sure. Are you I'm
going to say, are you running Let's just
copy this. Are you running the update?
If not, can you run can you update to
the
version? All right, the the March the
2nd version. So, let's just see what it
does in a second. If not, what I'm going
to do is just I'm going to grab the URL
from the change log at the top here, and
then we'll plug that back into OpenC
claw. Um, so now it's beginning to check
with OpenClaw to see whether it's done
or not. In the meantime, let me talk you
through what the other updates are.
Right? So, one of the other cool things
here is ACP agents sub agents are now on
by default. Now, if you're wondering
what ACP is, ACP stands for agent
communication protocol, right? It's like
a walkie-talkie system that lets
multiple AI agents talk to each other
and hand off tasks. Now, bear in mind
with ACP, you can even, for example, um
you can even use something like uh
clawed code with ACP if you've never
seen that before. And this is switched
on by default. Now, I'm sure you would
have to allow permissions to get it
using claude code, but you can see an
example of how this works. And this
means it can basically run like claude
code locally for you and a bunch of
other sub aents, right? So, your agents
can build teams, work together, um spawn
sub agents, that sort of thing, right?
So, if you're wondering, okay, what
changed? Well, previously you had to
manually turn this feature on. Now, it's
enabled automatically when you set up
open claw. Uh, so you could have like
one AI agent that handles custom
questions, another one that handles
scheduling. With ACP, they now
automatically pass tasks to each other
without you having to be middleman,
right? So ACP dispatch now defaults to
enabled. Um, and if you're upgrading
from the older version and you
specifically don't want agents talking
to each other, you can manually turn
this off with this command right here as
you can see. Right. So let's go back to
open claw. See what we're doing. And
it's like, yeah, your open claw is
already on the 2nd of March. So, this is
interesting because
the the button at the top doesn't work,
right? That it did update, but it
doesn't tell me. Um, so just make sure
it is running inside the chat if you
want to make sure, right? And if it's
struggling, all you do, I've done this
before, if it breaks, is like you copy
the URL over here, you go back to
openclaw, you paste it in the chat, and
you say update to this version, right?
Um, so that's how to update, how to fix
things. If you see any bugs or errors
like I've just seen, then you can fix it
quickly using this method. If we go back
to OpenClaw and the updates now, the
other thing is native PDF tools. So your
AI can now read your documents. Um, so
what changed is basically OpenClaw now
has a built-in PDF tool that lets your
AI assistant read, analyze, and work
with PDFs, right? And then
the supported AI providers include
Anthropic and Google with automatic
fallback for other AI models. What this
means is basically like you can upload a
PDF, the AI can read and summarize it.
You know, you could drop in like a
research paper, the AI answers questions
about it. You can send a client
proposal, the AI helps you actually edit
it as well. And there are configurable
limits which mean you can control how
large a PDF can be when you upload it
how many pages get processed and which
AI model handles the reading right um
the next one openclaw config validate
right so you can stop breaking things
before they break if that makes sense so
this is quite an interesting one what
changed is there's a brand new command
it's called openclaw config validate
right and what it does is before you
start up your entire openclaw setup you
can now check if your set settings are
correct first, right? So, basically,
it's like a spell checker, but for your
AI configuration on open core, it can
catch errors before they cause problems.
Now, this is useful for you because, you
know, like one typo in a config file uh
used to mean like hours of
troubleshooting, and I think we've all
been there with openclaw. Now, you can
run one command and it tells you exactly
what's wrong and where, right? And you
can even run openclaw validate JSON to
get a clean structured error report.
There's some other cool stuff as well.
So, for example, one of the most popular
messaging apps in Vietnam, Zalo, used by
over 70 million people, is now added
inside OpenClaw 2. And there's 100
security fixes. You can see a list of
all of them right here. Right. Um, some
other cool stuff that didn't make the
big headline. So, this is the big
headline inside the tweet in terms of
what came in. Um, but if we go back to
the updates, some other stuff worth
knowing. So, you can use locally hosted
AI for memory search. Now with Oama, you
can attach files when spawning sub
agents. You can reload the config. You
get transcripts of what the AI agent
actually heard if you want that. You can
do Docker health checks, which means you
can just check um if your Docker if
you're running it via Docker, you can
check if it's healthy or not, right? Um
and then you got funny startup messages
as well. So, it's called uh plug-in
banner taglines. And basically, this
means when it starts up, um it it gives
you funny messages. That's essentially
it.
So,
this is basically how it works. Um and
you you know, you might be wondering,
okay, who is this update for? So, let me
talk you through that, right? So, if
you're a business owner, then the PDF
tool and the Telegram updates are going
to give you like better customerf facing
AI bots, right? If you're an e-commerce
seller, then multi- aent ACP
coordination automates more of your
workflows. If you're a content creator,
the Telegram uh updates with live
messages just makes AI interactions feel
more natural for you and your audience,
especially if you're showing this stuff.
And then it can also use alarm memory
and it's got more security patches as
well. Um, if you're based in Vietnam,
obviously it's using Zo now. And if
you're just an AI hobbyist, then there's
100 extra fixes, which means things
actually work better now. And that's
basically it. So that's how to update.
That's how to use it. You can see it's
working quite nicely here. Pretty easy
to set up. Even for example, we uh
updated the CLI as well directly using
this too. And you can now use ACP
agents. So just to recap, the too long
didn't read. Open claw is a free tool
that connects AI models to messaging
apps and automates workflows. Version
the 2nd of March is one of the biggest
updates yet. The six big headline
features are Telegram live messages, ACP
sub agents on by default, native PDF
tool, the config validator, uh ZLO
plugin, and 100 security fixes. If
you're struggling, um you know how to
fix it as you've seen today. if you've
seen any issues and if you're new, this
is one of the best free AI automation
tools available right now and this
update just makes it better, right? And
the other thing I would say here is like
they seem to be prioritizing security in
each of these updates. So that's
basically how to get OpenClaw, how to
use it, how to set it up. If you want
all the links, we've got it inside the
video notes inside the air profit board
today. This also comes with a six-h hour
master class on OpenClaw and another
three-hour one as you can see right here
with full courses and setup guides and
everything else and all the best use
cases. We're constantly updating this
community with all the new updates. You
can see we've actually added one, two,
three uh six updates today on um the
newest updates. Yesterday we covered
mission control for openclaw, how to use
openclaw with uh clawed code as well.
We've also got other stuff on like open
call versus alternatives like
accomplish. I've pretty much tested like
all the big alternatives to open call.
Um that's basically how to use it. Now
if you want to check this out, this is
the AI profit board link in the comments
description or just go to the
aiprofitboard.com.
And if you want to learn how to save
time, scale, and grow with AI
automation. This one of the best places
inside the community. You'll get access
to 2,500 entrepreneurs who are doing
similar things as you. You get a daily
accountability group so you can check
in, post your goals, and stay 100%
focused. You can ask questions to get
help and support inside the community,
too. And I also post weekly updates,
right? So, I actually tell you what's
worth paying attention to and what to
ignore. As you can see right here, we
added a new weekly update today. Um, I
usually spend about 60 hours testing
this stuff each week. And so, like, I
just condense that down into like here's
the stuff to to figure out, here's the
stuff you should try, like top three
things, and then here's all the other
stuff you can ignore. And if you're
wondering, okay, like are people getting
results with stuff like this? You can
actually see we have over 133 pages of
wins from happy people inside our school
communities, right? So, you can see all
the wins, all the people getting results
with this stuff. It's pretty much an
infinite scroll as you can see right
here. Um, just loads of people getting
awesome results, which is great to see.
Uh, inside the community as well, you
get four weekly coaching calls. You can
jump on these video coaching calls, get
help, get support whenever you need to.
You can meet people in your local area.
Just zoom into the area that you want.
And then also inside the classroom, you
can see that we have a fiveweek master
class that takes you from beginner to
expert with AI automation and teaches
you how to build your first AI agent in
under five minutes. Additionally, you'll
learn all of my best playbooks I
personally run for my business. So, for
example, like AI avatar videos, shorts,
Instagram, newsletters, X, and
everything else. We also have a full
course for agencies. So, if you want to
learn how to get more clients, you can
check that out here. If you want to get
the latest updates, just check out this
section. You can see we update it every
day with the most important updates. And
then,
if you want to watch about the coaching
calls, you can do that over here. If you
want to learn how to rank one with AI
SEO, you can check that out. And also,
if you want to learn how to grow a
YouTube channel based on what's working
for me with AI, there's a training on
that, too.
So, let's just check out the questions.
I think we got one more from Naim who
says how to get Kimmy K 2.5 for free or
the miniax 2.5 right so there's a few
different ways let me I want to talk to
you but so what I would say one of the
easiest ways you can do this right is
you can actually go to
um in inside the onboarding for openclaw
you can select miniax right and if you
do the oorthth then you automatically
get opted in for free uh seven days for
free as a um free trial for miniax
coding. Right? So if you select miniax
on the onboarding for openclaw, then you
get 7 days to test out miniax for free
with open claw directly. Right?
Automatically um subscribes you to the
coding plan. So that's one option. The
other option is if you want to get Kim
K2.5 for free, you can do that with
OAMA, right? So you can check out Kim K
2.5 on O Lama. We actually have full
guides on both of these things as well
as GLM 4.7 flash.
So if you type in inside the air profit
boardroom, if you type in the search bar
GLM 4.7, then you can see how to set it
up inside this tutorial, which is a full
video guide plus a step-by-step process
that talks you through it. Right? If you
want to learn how to set up Kimik 2.5
with free, then you can check out this
video guide and the full setup
instructions right there. So whichever
setup you prefer is waiting inside there
for you. And then also if you want to
check out how to set up Miniax M2.5
then you can check this out directly
inside here as well. All right. So we
talk you through exactly how to set that
up with a video tutorial and a full
guide as you can see.
Another
question
is did your open claw break when you
updated? So today it didn't break
although it does seem to have a bug
because it tells you to update now
inside the dashboard even though you've
already updated. Right. So, we are
running um version the 2nd of March. As
you can see, it's confirmed inside the
chat. But when I click it, as you can
see right here with the notification, it
still tells me to update, right? Which
doesn't make sense if we're already
updated. So, it didn't break, but it it
got a little bit buggy. Um sometimes it
does break, but yeah, that's basically
it.
Shackle says, "What's the point in
Olama? They just chat." So with Oama,
you can actually run it with open claw
and then it doesn't just chat. It's an
actual full agent, right? So if you're
running with open claw or zero claw or
any of these sort of autonomous AI
agents, then you get the power of the
agent, but you get it for free with OAM
running locally. So it's not just a
chatbot.
Annie, good to see you here. Annie Ma,
legend in the SEO space. Thanks for
joining. Annie says, "So useful. Thanks
for showing us how it's done. AI feels
less intimidating now." Thank you so
much. And then
Shackle says other than Claude that came
with a CLI. Yeah. So I mean like you've
got you can access with OAM like tons of
different tools, right? It's pretty
cool. Um you might not be aware of it,
but like if we go to for example like
Kim K2.5 here, you can see that you can
run this for free, right? Um if you're
sticking within the token limits or just
running a local model, you can run these
tools with like claw code and codeex and
open code and o open claw, right? And
these normally are expensive to run with
APIs. So you can run them for free using
a localized version of for example like
Quen 3.5 and that sort of thing. So
that's the point of alarm. It's not just
a chatbot.
Click Sanger says, "Hey Julian, do you
know a better AI on OAMA than Quen 3
coder?" Yes, you want to check out my
tutorials on how to use um Quen 3.5. Now
Quen 3.5 just came out a few hours ago.
Super powerful. You can get different
versions of it and it performs at the
same sort of levels as like Claude Opus
4.5. Now, honestly, do I think they're
as good as something like uh Claude Opus
4.5? No. But if you want to run like a
powerful model locally, then go with
Quen 3.5. Right? So, basically what you
can see here is like they've got models
with the new version to match whatever
you can run locally, right? So, if
you're like on a super powerful computer
like a maybe a Mac Studio, then you
could run something like the 24 gig or
the 17 gig version, right? But if you're
on something that's quite slow or
doesn't have a lot of power, then you
can run the 08b version. That's the most
lightweight version. It's only 1 GB,
right? So, it can run locally. You can
use it offline. Um, and that's quite a
powerful model.
Let's see what else we got on the
questions here.
How do you decide the correct stack for
a task? So, I mean, for me, it's quite
easy to test them out and see what
performs, but I think everyone has their
own preferences, right? So, like for me,
it depends on the task itself. Like for
example, if I'm going to write content
or if I'm going to do something
workrelated, typically I will just use
Claude, right? Claude is like the best
model um when it comes to most stuff.
But if you need something that's like
fully autonomous like it's like do this
task, you walk away, you come back in a
couple hours, then I'll probably do
something like perplexity computer. Um
but the main thing is it comes with
experience. So I've got a lot of videos
on like different AIs you can use and I
would just look at them and see, okay,
which one do I want to use, which one do
I want to set up, etc. Right? Um, that's
the way that I would try and have a look
at it.
Any cost effective APIs you would
recommend? Yeah, for sure. Like, you
know, you've got Miniax, GLM5, and Kim K
2.5, right? So, these uh these models
are like super powerful, but they're
nowhere near as expensive as something
like Claude. So, I would just go with
one of those. They're a lot more
efficient. Clicker says, "Thank you,
sir. The best teacher on the planet."
Thank you so much. That's great. Um
Shackle says who's ah okay yeah so in
that in that situation right I'd have
I'd always have the most powerful API as
a brain and then it can delegate stuff
to for example Miniax communicative 5 or
for example GLM5 um as a sub agent right
so you can use the cheaper APIs as sub
aents and then you have claude as the
main brain because that's the smartest
AI so inside openclaw you can create sub
aents and then just say okay claude make
sure you're the brain and then you give
the APIs to everything else. Right?
That's basically how it works. Um, Urban
says, "I'd love you to do a video on
null claw." I've actually already done
one. You can check that out inside the
AR profit boardroom. So, if you go
inside the classroom here and then you
go to SOP updates, we have a full video
tutorial on null claw. We set it up, we
tested it, we we created a 30-day road
map for it and also 100 prompts on how
to use it, right? So, if you want to
check that out, that's inside uh here as
you can see.
And Urban says, "Your content is
awesome. That avatar had me fooled for a
few minutes."
Thank you so much. No, I appreciate
that. Thank you. Um, we do try and be
really transparent about when we use the
avatar and that sort of thing, but I
appreciate you checking it out. So,
thanks. All right.
Coport just dropped and it might be the
biggest contender to competing with open
claw we've ever seen. Now Alibaba, one
of the biggest tech companies on the
planet, just released their own free AI
agent. You can see the announcement
right here. here. So, this is a tweet
from AI search and you can see that
Tongi Lab actually announced that Coport
was available right here. Um, and
basically
this is running via a free AI agent. It
does almost everything Open Claw does.
It can run on your computer. It
remembers everything. It works on its
own 24/7. Now, here's where it gets wild
because Copore apparently can actually
do things OpenClaw cannot do right now.
things that once you see them, you'll
wonder how you ever used agents without
them. So today, we're going to check it
out and just see how it runs. If you
want to take a look at it, it's open
source. You can see on GitHub right
here. This is Copore and this is running
from Alibaba, right? This is your
personal assistant. Easy to install. You
can deploy it. It was fairly easy to set
up. What I would say is when you're
using this, use something like Claude
Code to help you get it set up because
it can be a little bit of work unless
you're super technical. And you can see
an example right here. Now, this is a
preview in Chinese, but you can run it
in English as you can see. And then to
run it, it's just like a oneline install
like this. You can also run it using
Docker, which is what I did today. And
then once you've done that, you can
actually set it up with like local
models or all sorts of models that you
want to use, right? So, here's an
example of how it runs. If you go over
to the Coport console over here, this is
Coport, right? And you can see, for
example, we actually created this
landing page. So inside the chat, one of
the first things I would say is like it
did even when I selected English, it
started speaking to me in Chinese,
right? So you can see an example of it
speaking to me in Chinese here. Um, and
then what we actually did was we just
said like just reply in English and then
it switched back to English here. And
from there, I actually wanted to run a
test to create a website. Right now the
website itself is pretty awesome. Like
look at this website that it's created
and it just built this using the prompt
that I'll give you. So, it was a oneshot
prompt. It just went off and created the
whole page, which is pretty crazy. Like
all the FAQs um were created. The colors
are pretty nice, very colorful, very
interesting. Actually looks better than
the original in many ways. And if we go
back to Cop, I'll show you how we did
this. So, literally you can use it
inside the chat here. So, you can say,
for example, like build a beautiful um
fun landing page that's easy to use and
then actually just pasted in the
information from the AR profitable
boardroom into the chat. Now, from
there, it said, "Sure, I'll build you
this. Let me create something that hits
different." Blah, blah, blah. And it
went off, created it. You can see that
it's sort of coding out right there. And
it's like done, I've created this.
Here's the link to it. So, it's actually
coded locally. And here's why it's good,
etc. Here's the key sections that it's
added. And it's like, if you want any
tweaks or anything like that, just let
me know. Now, the one thing that I'll
say here is like the browser use was not
working so well. So what I'd recommend
is that if you want it to use browser
use properly, just go back into claw
code and get it configured properly. But
it was pretty easy to set up. And the
interesting thing is on the left hand
side here, you can see that you can
select like channel sessions, chron
jobs, and heartbeat just like open claw,
right? It really does um it must be like
a open- source version that was built
around openclaw in the first place. Now
if we go to the settings over here, you
can see that you can switch between
different settings. And I'm actually
running this with OAMA, right? So this
is running uh we can run it locally with
Olama. You can choose which for example
um which model you want to use inside
the list. So you can run this completely
for free and it's quite easy to set up
the API right. So for example we could
run this with quen 3.5. We could run
this with for example GLM 4.7 and these
are both local free models so that
number one copore is free to set up
because you can just run it from GitHub
and then OAMA is free to to set up and
run locally as well right and then
you've got an autonomous AI agent
running locally on your laptop just like
openclaw and it's just running for free
24/7. Pretty crazy. Now if we go over to
the workspace here you can quickly edit
your files and that sort of thing. I
want to see as well actually. Can we can
we change it to um to dark mode? Right.
So, right now it's pretty bright. That's
that's what I would prefer it if it was
in dark mode. It doesn't seem to be, but
I wonder if you can switch it in some
way. I'm sure you could if I played
around with it a bit more. And then you
can run it with all your main sort of
models, right? The main one I would
probably focus on if I was you um if
you're testing this out is just using
the free Olama as you can see over here,
right? any bugs or anything like that,
just go over to Claude Code and say,
"Can you help me fix this?" or "This
isn't working," blah blah blah. That's
what I did when I had a couple of
problems with it set up. But literally
got it set up within about I would say
10 to 15 minutes and it was pretty
simple. Now, you can add MCP clients
over here, right? Which means you can
link this to tools um just by pasting in
the MCP details over here with your API
keys. And that means that basically you
can make this even more powerful by
linking it to tools externally and then
your autonomous AI agent with copore can
go off and start doing stuff. Um the
other thing that I would say here is
like it doesn't break on me as much as
something like open claw and I'll give
you an example like a real practical
example from today. So for example with
openclaw here we've already updated to
the latest version but it's still got a
notification to update at the top which
doesn't make sense if we've already
updated right we're already on the
latest version. So just something to be
aware of there. Now the other thing that
I like as well is that you see on this
section here you can add multiple chats
right which means that you can have
parallel agents working on multiple
different tasks at the same time. So for
example we could say okay code a
pomoduro timer over here right then we
could go over to this chat and we could
say okay code a fun
snake game. Right? Something like that.
Right? And then we can have multiple
chats running with the AI agent and just
they're all working in parallel
together. Right? That's a pretty simple
and easy way to to just have multiple
chats working so that you can have these
agents um working in parallel and you
can have different stuff running at the
same time. Now let's have a look inside
the chat here.
See what we got. I'm going to I'm going
to come back to these questions actually
in a second. So um we focus on on this
particular update. Now you can see we
have multiple sessions running here. So
you can switch between sessions. You can
set up uh schedule tasks just like you
would with openclaw.
You've got the heartbeat file which
basically is like this will send you
updates, right? And so every few hours
you can get updates. Um and you can
change the interval. So you can say okay
update me every hour or something like
that. And then you've got sessions and
channels, right? So with with the
channels you can actually link this to
Discord. I couldn't see an option for
Telegram, but you can link it to
Discord, QQ, um a couple other Chinese
messaging apps, but probably the main
one that most people watching this would
use is Discord, but you can use the UI,
right? Um and that's basically how it
works. So,
you just put in the chat here what you
want to do. um because it's using no
lumber, it's obviously going to be a
little bit slower, but you can see it
does actually work and it does it does
work directly here. So, that's basically
how to use it. It's pretty simple to set
up. Would I say it's as good as
something like open claw? Probably not.
Um it was a little bit buggy when it was
using browser control, whereas browser
control seems to work fine if you're
using something like openclaw. Um but I
think either way, it's just interesting
to test these alternatives out. And the
overall trend here is like things are
becoming more autonomous. More agents
are being released. Alibaba is obviously
taking this seriously because you can
see um how it's working. And then you
can also see here that we've created
this Pomodoro timer, right? Um using the
local API from Alarma. So it didn't cost
us anything to to set that up as well,
which is pretty cool.
Now, let's just have a little preview of
it.
So yeah, that's how the page looks like.
Um, pretty simple and easy to set up.
And then we've got the timer ready to go
here. Right. So, this is the Pomodoro
timer we just asked Copore to create,
which you can see right here. Um, it's
working perfectly. Pretty interesting
design. Pretty cool. It's got an alarm
as well at the top. And then you can
reset the timer as well. And then you
actually get like um a streak at the
bottom so you can track how many
sessions you've done. So, it's all
working fine. It seems to create stuff
pretty cool. Um the the one of the
biggest differences I think is like you
get the chat options so you can come
back to your history and that sort of
thing. And then also just seems a lot
easier to configure because you can
switch between APIs and the settings. So
that just makes it a lot easier as you
can see.
Now, just to recap here, um we do have
like a 30-day system for building AI
agents with Copore inside the video
notes from today inside the AR profit
boardroom. Um and you might be
wondering, okay, what is Copore? Why
does it actually matter? So, it's an
open source AI agent built by Alibaba's
Tongi Lab team, right? It was fully open
sourced on February the 28th and it's
got a long-term memory that actually
works. It remembers your preferences. No
more starting from scratch. Local vector
search. It runs locally first. So it
runs natively of Llama as you've seen
today, which means you can run it for
free and it's it's all like sort of
running locally for you. You can connect
it to multiple different message
channels. And the interesting thing here
is you can actually build your own
channel plugins, right, with a
standardized protocol, which is pretty
cool. So
the biggest difference I think between
these is like if you look at something
like Copore, it's really designed and I
think this is this sort of coincides
with Quen 3.5 coming out which is local,
free, and really powerful from Alibaba.
Um I think they've designed this AI
agent to work alongside Quen 3.5. And
then you can see here there's a 30-day
road map if you want to test this out.
We've got day-to-day um prompts for
really mastering this if you want to
check out and how to use it and that
sort of thing. And then we've got 100
prompts as you can see down here uh to
test this out. So just to recap, Copore
is Alibaba's open source AI agent. It
was released end of February. Local
first, memory first, model modular
architecture. Zero cost because you can
run it with alarm. It connects to
Discord, iMessage, and a bunch of other
messaging apps. In terms of copore
versus openclaw, so both are powerful.
Copore is more local, right? Whereas
open claw is more cloud-based when
you're using APIs unless you're running
it locally as well with alarm. Um and
it's just like different philosophies
and different UI as well I would say.
So thanks so much for watching. If you
want to get all the video notes from
today, you can get that inside the AR
profit boarding. We actually have a full
6-h hour course on openclaw if you want
to check that out and another 3-hour
course on openclaw right here. And we
add new daily updates inside the profit
boardroom. As you can see, this is my AI
automation community, the AI profitable
link in the comments description or go
to a profitable.com. And this basically
shows you how to save time, scale, and
grow with AI. Now, inside the community,
we have 2,500 members, so you can ask
questions, get help, get support
whenever you need it. There's always
people online to help. Um, what you can
also do, for example, is you can go
inside the calendar and get video calls,
live automation, AI automation coaching,
so you can ask questions, meet the
community, ask any questions you have.
if you ever get stuck, they're great to
go on. Inside the map, you can actually
zoom into your local area and then meet
people in your local area and that sort
of thing.
And then additionally, inside the
classroom, you'll get all my best
trainings. Now, at this point, you might
be saying, "Okay, are people actually
getting results with this?" So, we have
133 pages of of testimonials at this
point. It's it's basically an endless
scroll. And
what's cool about this is, as you can
see right here, there's lots of people
winning with this stuff, right? So, it's
it's it's something where you can go
learn AI, get results. I mean, for
example, Russell was selling AI avatar
videos. Eric landed a new client. Dan
got his first customer in two weeks.
Like, and there's 133 pages of people
getting results like that. So, it's a
pretty awesome community and definitely
worth checking out.
Let's see what questions we've got.
So Rowit says, "Hey Julian, I have an
old Windows laptop. I'm trying to set up
OpenClaw in it. What AI stack do you
suggest me to run in it?" So I mean just
use the normal stuff, right? So for
example, like you can set up Miniax or
uh GLM or Kimik 2.5 if you want a cheap
API and then just just run it locally in
your terminal. You you don't need to
overthink it. Like it can run um however
you want. Faso says, "Updating to 3.2
now. How long did it take?" Literally
took like a couple of minutes for me to
upgrade.
Copore can use Miniax 2.5 free. Not as
far as I know, but it can run local
models. So, it can run Quen 3.5 free,
for example, and it's set up to to be
able to sort of run the API directly
inside the settings with OAM.
Is there a possible way to spawn sub
agents to delegate tasks on Copore? I
think there probably is. I've just not
checked that out but I think like for
example sub aents which are a feature of
open claw you could probably easily set
up inside inside coore as well
and then shackle says what about visual
and documents for coort yeah so like you
can create documents you can create um
if if you gave it the API details so if
you for example said okay here's my API
for Google AI studio here's how to set
up nanana banana 2 um here's the
documentation for it could easily set
that up right in the same way that you
would set that up with open claw.
And then Urban says, "What's the best
local LLM for development work on O
Lama?" So yeah, I would I mean it's
that's a really good question. So I
would recommend we've got a bunch of
training on it here. What I would
recommend is that you check out Quen 3.5
first because it's got some awesome
models that have just been released in
there. It's really good for coding,
right? Um, you can also, for example, as
you've seen today, we use GLM 4.7 Flash
to create this page and also the
Pomodoro timer, right? And it coded them
out perfectly, right? So, there was no
issues. Um, it seems to work really
nice. It's done some nice designs like
right up there with something board
would do. And so, you can easily code
out locally with uh GLM 4.7 Flash as
well. It depends on your setup as well,
though. That's the main thing, too.
some other use cases for this as well
like you could you could use open claw
to help you come up with like content
ideas or copore as well. Um we actually
do have a full sixhour course here on
like all the use cases for this sort of
stuff. So if you want like examples of
recommended skills and what we use for
this sort of stuff, you can check it out
right here.
Claw X just changed how everyone uses
OpenClaw. Most people have no idea
exists yet. So right now, OpenClaw is
one of the most powerful AI agent
systems on the planet. It can work for
you 24/7. automate your tasks, talk to
apps, schedule jobs, all of it. But
there's one massive problem. You have to
use command line to run it. Um, that's
like having a Ferrari, but the only way
to drive it is with a manual written in
Japanese. So, Claw X fixes that. And
this is a brand new free desktop app
that puts OpenClaw inside a clean,
beautiful um, UI, as you can see right
here. And this runs via a desktop app,
which is pretty cool. Now, this is a
brand new free desktop app that
basically helps you use OpenClaw, but
you don't need to type commands. You
don't need any confusing setup. There's
no technical needed. You just install it
through a setup wizard and then your AI
agent is live. And I actually got
OpenClaw to set up directly. So, I'll
show you exactly how I got that to work.
And we can run through that in a second.
So if you go back to open claw
which you can see right here
What I literally did and this was really
easy to set up. I just got the GitHub
details of claw X. So it's a free open
source project on GitHub as you can see.
I took the URL of GitHub then plugged it
into openclaw and said install this for
openclaw please. Right. And it kind of
creates claw X. And as you can see this
is running locally. But the interesting
thing about this is it's it's inside a
desktop app. It almost feels like called
co-work and that sort of thing. Um,
which is pretty powerful. Now, it took a
few minutes to generate, but then once
it did, it gives me an overview of what
it's doing, how it works, etc. Um, it
sets it up automatically inside the
chat, so you can see. And then it will
tell you, okay, this is set up and good
to go. Right now, also, for example,
asked me, it's it said installed now, as
you can see. Um, but it did ask me like,
do you want to set this up as an app
inside Mac OS? And I was like, yeah,
let's do that. Right. And then from
here, we actually got the full app as
you can see. So, inside the desktop app,
we've got Telegram, Discord, WhatsApp.
It just makes it way easier to manage
and it's a pretty clean UI as well. So,
you can see we've got Discord connected
here and it gives you kind of like this
mission control as well. So, you got
like how many connected. Um, you can
easily like set up a new channel as well
if you want to set up a new channel
here. So you can click on Telegram, add
the bot token and the allowed user IDs.
So it's really easy to connect other
apps. You could add WhatsApp and that
sort of thing as well. Just scan the QR
code. You can also, for example, go to
the dashboard here. This kind of like
mission control where you can see the
gateway, what skills you've set up,
everything else. And then you've got all
the models you're using over here.
Inside the settings, you can change
between light and dark. You can change
the language, the AI providers that you
have. So, it's quite easy to, for
example, add uh other APIs like you
could even add O Lama and run this for
free locally as well, which is pretty
cool. And then you can add custom AIs
here. But, Anthropic, OpenAI, Google,
they're all available. And that means
you can just configure the setup of your
OpenClaw way faster by doing this. And
it's super easy to do. You can also
download the latest updates inside this
section. You've got the dashboard,
channels, skills, schedule tasks, and
then the main chat, right? So, you can
actually just chat with openclaw um
directly inside the chat here. So, if
you say, "Hey, are you working?" This
will be connected to my open claw. And
the cool thing about all of this is you
can easily get it to
um to you can easily get open core to
set this up yourself, right? Which means
you you don't even need to like run the
terminal commands to set it up as well,
which is pretty cool, right? And you can
see here it's it's working directly,
which is awesome. So, let's see what we
got inside the questions here.
Greg says, "Hey, aren't you finding open
core so full of bugs?" Absolutely. Yeah,
it's very buggy. I mean, that's what
you're going to get with like open
source projects, right?
open source projects, you're always
going to get issues where it's like, you
know, um
where it's, for example, like breaking
or struggling or that sort of thing,
right? And it happens all the time. So,
um I would just be aware that this can
happen. There's some issues from time to
time. Um but yeah, you could you you're
going to get that with like open source
projects. It's not like Claude where you
know it's a really clean smooth
experience. Even like the updates in
section here it struggles with. But
that's basically how to set up Claw X.
Um that's how to run it. You can see
here it's running inside the chat. I've
shown you how it works etc. Um and you
can run it just as a application which
is pretty cool.
It's also quite easy to create schedule
tasks and manage your schedule tasks as
you can see.
And the other thing here is as well like
it's kind of managing all the all the
problems that people have, right? So for
example, people struggle with the the
terminal setup on open claw. So with
this, you just have like a one-click
installation. The configuration files
can be quite difficult, but with claw X,
you get like the visual um real-time
validation and that sort of thing. And
then there's process management, uh
multiple AI providers, and it's much
easier to like uh add skills and plugins
and that sort of thing.
So that's basically how to use it, how
to set up, how to get it working. Again,
I've shown you what it looks like. It's
pretty cool. Um, definitely worth
checking out. It again, it does feel
like almost like the the claude co-work
if that makes sense. And you can get
open claw to just set up inside the
chat. Just paste in the GitHub details.
So, thanks so much for watching. If you
haven't already, check out the AR profit
boarding. We've got tons of video notes
as you can see right here. Um, we've
also got a full framework on how to use
this, a 30-day plan on how to set up a
bunch of use cases here as well, and
also 100 prompts on how you can test
this out with claw X and just decide
like, you know, do you prefer the
desktop app or the gateway or that sort
of thing. Um, so that's basically how it
works. Now, inside the AR profit
boarding as well, we have a full
six-hour course on how to master Open
Claw with step-by-step guides and that
sort of thing. We have another
three-hour course here, and we update
this every single day with new updates.
So, for example, Quen 3.5 released a new
model you can run with OpenClaw this
morning. We've already done a video
tutorial on full step-by-step guide
here. And we actually date the updates.
You can see for example, second of
March, 1st of March, etc. And we're
adding new updates every single day. So,
this is all inside the AI profit board
link in the comments description or go
to the apiprofitboard.com.
Inside the community, you can post
questions, get help, get support.
There's always people online cuz there's
2,500 people inside here. I also do
weekly updates. Now, inside the weekly
AI updates, what I do is I look at my 60
hours of research each week with AI, and
I break down what's useful and what's
not, just to save you time and to help
you avoid information overload. We also
have a daily accountability group. And
again, this just helps you avoid
information overload so you can stay
focused and and just really focus on
what matters to you most. Right now,
inside the classroom, you can get all of
our best trainings. So, for example, if
you want to go from beginner to expert
with AI automation, you can do that
here. Plus, learn how to build your
first AI agent in under 5 minutes.
Additionally, you can get our playbook
which shows you how to automate X,
newsletters, shorts, avatar videos, and
everything else.
Inside the SAP updates, you can get
daily updates like you can see right
here, um, with all the new guides and
that sort of thing. And then you can
also go inside the map and meet people
in your local area.
Additionally, you can learn how to get
more clients with the agency course. You
can watch about the coaching calls. You
can learn how to rank number one with AI
SEO and also how to grow a YouTube
channel with AI based on what's working
for me. So, that's all inside the AI
profit boardroom
link in the comments description or go
to the AI profitboarding.com.
Shackle says, "Are the tears to claw a
better or worse?" Yeah, there's there's
plenty of alternatives I've tested that
have just not been as good. Um, we've
got loads of guides inside here. Does
copore support open router? I think it
does as far as I'm aware. I think so.
Are there tiers to claw? Uh, we already
answered that one. Um, does claw x
update open claw automatically? Well,
you just set up auto updates inside the
gateway of or if you want to
automatically update.
Um, rot says, I want to build an
autonomous job application setup. Yes,
you can. I I've done that with the way
that I did that before. I built a job
board with um data button. Data button
was the uh one that I used and we have a
full tutorial on how I did that right
here. Right. So, we have a full tutorial
on how data button work right there.
So, that's basically how it works.
Thanks very much for watching.
Appreciate as always. I've answered all
the questions. Thanks for being on
today. I'll see you on the next one.
Cheers. Bye-bye.